- So, you shot the movie in London right?
You were saying?
(audience applauds)
- Yeah, yeah.
- So, like did you do anything fun
while you were there or just work?
- No, I got to do a lot of fun stuff.
Like I, it was a six week
shoot, it was really crammed
and I worked for two weeks,
then the kids came out for two weeks
and then, I shot for two weeks.
We ate our way across London.
It was...
- They have great Indian Food.
- They have, Dishoom, the best.
- So good.
- And they have like, there's
this incredible Italian place
called Lina Stores, we just ate our way.
And we took the kids
like, on the London Eye.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And there's really great parks there,
it was, it was wonderful.
- My kids on the London Eye was hilarious,
because they started out, they
were so excited at the edge
and then, like slowly they backed up.
- Right, right, right.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
- When it started going high.
(Kelly laughs)
- It's kinda intense.
- Yeah, they were like,
"Yeah, this is so great".
- [Kristen] Yeah.
- It was like...
(audience laughs)
I was like, "Why are you moonwalking?
Like what's happening?
What are you doing right now?"
I heard that you also
did something really fun,
involving stripping.
- Oh, my gosh, so...
(audience laughs)
Yes.
- I need to know this story.
- I can't believe I didn't lead with that.
In London, I had a transformative
experience emotionally,
because Ben took me to see "Magic Mike".
(audience applauds)
And...
- Which one?
- He took, okay, so Karan
Soni is also in the movie,
so Ben Platt, Karan Soni,
Allison Janney and I,
went to see "Magic Mike" at this casino.
Which like, those things if
you're pitching a night to me,
are not normally my vibe.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I'm like, "Oh, maybe, sure".
I would get nervous.
- Yeah, you don't commit
so you can back out.
- Exactly.
- Yeah.
- It was passionate, it was gorgeous.
(audience chuckles)
There was audience participation.
It had story, I like came
out, it had empowerment.
I came out like, feeling the
London air as like a new woman.
I can't describe it, but it
is not just a strip show.
So, see "Magic Mike" if you can.
That's my, that's what I'm saying.
(audience applauds)
- I love how passionate you are.
- It was so much fun.
- I've never seen it.
- It's not so much, it's
sexy, but it's more like,
passionate and beautiful
and really empowering
for both males and females
and everyone in between.
And it's just like, raucous
but also really safe.
(Kelly laughs)
- I just imagine like,
I imagine this coming out of a man,
coming out of a strip club and being like,
"You don't understand,
there's so much story".
(audience laughs)
- There's so much story.
- It was beautiful and I felt so safe.
- It's not just about the
wings, Hooters are great.
(Kristen laughs)
It's like, it's like
I just heard it coming
from a male perspective,
trying to sell me on it
and I'm like, "Okay".
- This is not that, this is not that.
- No, no, even if that is, you do you.
- Right.